e tutta la gente che si lamenta questo
non nota del brutto natale diverso e non
solo è stata così felice così modesti
mamme natale
iscriviti al canale per non perdere
neanche un video a regà tranquilli lo
sapete il regalo io più grande come
direbbe il grande tiziano non sono
regali materiali e chi vuoi studiare che
voi andate bene al lavoro capito queste
cose qua che non si possono toccare
non importa se io mi sono fatta un mazzo
tanto che ho fatto 10 10 regali a testa
e voi nun me l'avete fatto non importa
veramente non è un problema lo giuro ma
una tale data non esiste più cara guarda
non c'è più la tradizione non c'è più il
natale di una volta è infatti da
quest'anno ne androne niente figurati a
questo ma sai che non avevo ancora visto
ma l'avranno fatto i bambini guarda loro
ci tengono sai
ecco i vostri ricamava prima di aprire i
regali faremo una bella preghiera tutti
insieme avvicinatevi padri nostro grazie
per averci permesso di stare tutti
insieme vicino che rendiamo la piu ha
piu reale questa pregare inginocchiato
gravi ragazzi continuiamo guarda bella
so proprio contenta per la prima volta i
miei figli staranno a tavola magna zitti
e muti dopo questo fatto ammazzo tanta
cucina ci mancherebbe d'altronde gli
anni scorsi uscivano andavano in
discoteca
quest'anno no city modi a maglia non
ragazzi non ci siamo picca questa musica
da trappers e io mica l'auto risata è no
adattare si mette solo michael brook
l'eroe sapete se non si mangiano tutto
quello che ho cucinato non ce ne sono
problemi perché se lo mangiano per tutto
il 2021
a questo servono i congelatori a questo
regalo a cristo reja rosino incanti
insieme a me non avrai più rigali o
sottoinsieme regala siamo niente regali
o ma figurati a me fa solo che piacere
che bisogna stare a casa con pochi
parenti
così hanno scusa perfetta se mi chiama
qualcuno che vuole passare a trovarmi
pronto sia a vuoi passare per il
panettone o ma guarda mi dispiace
tantissimo
ma perché abbiamo appena raggiunto il
numero massimo di persone prima di
scambiarci regali
vorrei che ci dice sì ma tutte quelle
cose che abbiamo sempre voluto dirci ma
non ci siamo mai detti no calogero
quelle no mai capito un sogno proprio il
primo natale senza misura uscirà a morte
mi ha vista anna tesoro che stava fa
stavo a piagne non sai quanto mi
dispiace guarda quest'anno che non
facciamo ornata l'insieme stava piani
guarda me mancherà ma montaldo di più
mokbel aziende ma cosa si fa poi le
abbiamo fatto room maledetti abbassate
questa musica sarà ho pensato una tale
così triste col colonna sviste non
chiamo c un po di share e basta zie di
michael bublè bella sia vuole entrare
per i paesi delle sette carta è cosa ci
si ferma ma che peccato non vedere un
agente così by luca 007 arrivederci
[Musica]